there is a very disturbing video of
police aggressively arresting an
eight-year-old for allegedly stealing a
bag of potato chips in syracuse new york
now originally this story was reported
as
a ten-year-old boy that was being
really treated like an adult for
allegedly stealing a bag of potato chips
we have since learned that this is
actually
as of right now believed to be an
eight-year-old could that also be wrong
maybe but as far as we know right now
this is an eight-year-old i'm gonna play
the video the video is disturbing not in
a gory sense it's just disturbing in
terms of how these police officers are
treating uh this kid let's take a look
[Music]
if he breaks into your house to steal
something nah maybe what are you saying
a bag of chips so y'all treat me like a
whole cold bloody killer
walking dude you don't even know you
keep walking dude i didn't know what i
just came up and see i know i just came
up and see okay what did you say i see
y'all snatching him up a
all right now the the kid is black and
um
we i mean we we have to consider the
racial component here
and i i i told the story on our live
stream yesterday when i was
i think i was like 10 or 11
and my little brother was eight or nine
we went grocery shopping
and we get home and i remember this like
it was yesterday because it was so
notable to me we get home
and my brother pulls out a king-size
snickers bar not even the normal size
this is the big boy you know it's like
uh it it's like a huge steel rod you
know the king-size snickers
and my mom said to my brother sir where
did you get that no she didn't call him
sir um she said where where'd you get
that
and he says the grocery store
and
what do you mean where was it it was at
the checkout you know
i got it
and my mom
explained no no we we can't do that
that's stealing you can't do that and to
teach the lesson
uh they went back to the grocery store
and they said
he
took this and we didn't pay for it so
we're coming back to return it
and you know management was like oh
thank you so much for being honest you
know what for your honesty go ahead and
keep it and i think my mom insisted on
paying for it then you know to teach a
lesson and whatever and it was really
notable and it sticks out in my mind and
it was like this is the way that things
are supposed to be done
imagine if police were involved for the
for the snickers it would it would just
be outrageous it wouldn't be
it wouldn't be justice it wouldn't be
educational it wouldn't be something
that would point my brother in the right
direction when it comes to a place i
mean there's just no upside to handling
it in that way
now my brother wasn't black at the time
he's still not black in fact some people
might be shocked that he's still not
black so
obviously we have this question of the
racial component would this would this
situation have been handled the same way
if a white kid had stole you know a
jelly bean or whatever the case may be
we can't say because they're two
different situations but it certainly
doesn't look good we've now heard from
the
um uh no this is the wrong story we've
now heard from the mayor of syracuse who
weighed in this is mayor ben walsh and
said that he was concerned when he saw a
boy put in the back of a cruiser
after allegedly stealing a bag of chips
and the mayor said from what he saw the
boy wasn't placed in handcuffs the
officer knew the child from prior
interactions and explained to him he was
being taken home the officers returned
the child to his family and discussed
the incident before leaving without
filing any charges so it seems as though
the perspective they're taking is sort
of like well listen he wasn't cuffed he
wasn't arrested he wasn't charged he was
just basically taken home and explained
you know he was it was explained to him
why what he did was wrong but the
manhandling is absolutely absurd even
the placing in the back of the police
car i mean listen again
when i was growing up
when an officer got involved in one of
these let me help right let me be the
positive influence
you put the kid in the front right and
now you could say well but sometimes the
police cars have the laptops in the
front
the entire handling is wow this is a
criminal and unfortunately this is
exactly the type of thing that can point
people kids to adversarial perspectives
with police it can point them in the
direction of repeating these actions in
the future so it's all horrible now
meanwhile
earlier in the week i mentioned
there was a shooting in syracuse and
it's not like there's a shortage of
other stuff police can be involved in
there were like four officers involved
at least with this eight-year-old kid uh
we now have learned that a syracuse man
has been arrested in that armory square
shooting that i told you about from over
the weekend and so it's not even a case
of like there's nothing else to do in
syracuse it's not a direct line where
like if these four officers weren't you
know taking this kid uh um into custody
or whatever um that they would have been
involved in solving or preventing that
shooting okay i get that but
there is not a sort of there's nothing
for police to be doing in syracuse sort
of situation so let me know your
thoughts many people outraged over this
some saying the police handled it fine
that's not my perspective but i would
love to hear from you you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
i hope that you viewers listeners to our
show take your privacy seriously things
i talk about all the time internet
service providers record what you do
online they sell the data it's there for
eternity
big tech companies search engines social
media they're tracking almost everything
you do
they hang on to that information forever
too
i don't let all of these corporations
spy on me i hope you don't either
because avoiding all of it is simple and
affordable today i use atlas vpn to make
myself invisible online one subscription
covers all my devices you don't have to
be a tech person you just install it
once you press a button you forget about
it you enjoy your privacy if you don't
use a vpn a record of your internet
activity will always exist and change
hands tech companies make money off of
you respect your own privacy enough to
install a vpn it's so easy
click the link below to get atlas vpn
for 82 percent off less than two bucks a
month and you'll get one month for free